[Music]
these grapes could give French
winemakers a headache on this particular
part of Chardonnay at the back there we
can get some quite tropical kind of
right almost like stone fruit flavors
coming through tropical in this kind of
weather here in East Sussex in
southeastern England the organic grapes
take more time to ripen and they're
harvested later than in most of
continental Europe we don't have a lot
of Sun we don't have a lot of heat so
it's kind of growing a lovely delicious
product you know considering those
circumstances we are here in October and
we're still picking grapes
kristan silt avec used to work as a PR
advisor now she's a wine grower in part
thanks to climate change it does rain a
lot here in East Sussex but temperatures
are rising steadily making conditions
ideal for the British sparkling wine
which could give France's Champagne
region some competition champagne used
to be a relatively marginal climate it
was colder for growing grapes and making
wine now is warmer there and it's it's I
had a chap here who visited the vineyard
from champagne and he was from a
champagne growing making family and he
said that the climate in the UK is
similar to when he grew up in Champagne
40 years ago grower Ben Smith is
confident that the English grapes can
take on French Champagne there's a lot
of tastings out there that have happened
blind tastings pitching the best English
sparkling wines against champagnes in a
blind tasting so nobody can see the
label and English wines have come out
and competed with the best yeah does
this mean that Britain might one day be
self-sufficient in wine production and
independent of the rest of Europe
an unofficial taste test shows that this
is no understatement
at least when it comes to bubbly Britain
can free itself from the continent so
we're not too worried
compared with Germany and France and
Italy of course so we don't produce
anywhere near the quantity but it's nice
to know that this this we can produce
some really tasty stuff Kristen and Ben
are pleased with this year's harvest the
wine growers have big plans for the
upcoming years nothing less than
invading the native country of champagne
I would love to sell some wine to France
I haven't actually had any inquiries but
you know I had lots of inquiries from
the countries around France you know
bordering France so hopefully one day
you'll find me in a restaurant in Paris
that will be great wouldn't it but first
she'll have to boost production kristen
has already bought some more land to
further her wine growing ambitions
[Music]